Being your First Lady has been the greatest honor of my life,...
...and I hope I've made you proud.
For all the young people in this room and those who are watching,...
...know that this country belongs to you, to all of you.
Do not ever let anyone make you feel like you don't matter...
...or like you don't have a place in our American story because you do.
And when you encounter obstacles, because I guarantee you you will,...
...and many of you already have,...
...when you are struggling and you start thinking about giving up,...
...I want you to remember something that my husband and I have talked about...
...since we first started this journey nearly a decade ago.
Something that has carried us through every moment in this White House...
...and every moment of our lives, and that is the power of hope.
The belief that something better is always possible...
...if you're willing to work for it and fight for it.
Because that is what moves this country forward every single day.
Our hope for the future and the hard work that hope inspires.